[Music]
so today I'm going to talk about
selecting and doing with tidy even and
the goal will be to create a function
around tidy verse pipelines and to show
you the easy way to do that
Jenny a shout a bit of it it's passing
the dots so diverse functions and we'll
focus on two flavors of Thai diva
selecting and doing so to come back on
the reason why we have tied ever to put
more context the goal is really to
change the context of computation so for
example if we have this filter function
where you pass a data frame and
filtering expressions we want to take
these expressions and evaluate them in
the context of the data frame so you you
have the equivalent base our code on the
right side where you have to be specific
about whether the columns come from and
it even goes further because we can
change the context of computation to
like foreign databases and we can
translate the your filtering expressions
to sequel query so we need to ideal for
that because if we use normal functions
you would get this object not found
error because our does not know about
height object and that's why we really
need to delay the computation of these
expressions we need to we need to
prevent evolution from happening and so
that's what we mean by quoting quoting
means that we delay the computation and
then we change the context and we
resumed the computation and so Kotick
code it's a bit like a blueprint for the
computation it tells our what what to do
to get a result and the program when we
have quoted code like this that's now
when you program
against functions that work on
blueprints you need to modify the
Brooklands and that's why we have
bangbang which is like surgery operator
for the for blueprints so we'll talk
about two flavors of Tidy evaluation
that we have in a tidy verse and here we
have four functions from the player
mutate group by select and filter and
they look a bit the same you use it in
the same way but there's actually one
that's different from the other it
select because select takes a selection
all the other functions takes take
actions what we mean by action is that
so we get this blueprint and we use it
to create new vectors and then we modify
the data frame whereas with selections
something different happens we match the
columns to their position in the data
frames and then there is no creation of
vectors there and so in actions when we
get the blueprint we that's pretty much
normal our our code but in selections we
have a few special features there of to
start with the C function and the minus
and current operators they understand
positions and current names and that's
how you can really see specify a range
of current for example with the colon
operator and then you can also use
selection helpers which are very useful
because they know about variables that
you are currently working working with
and so for example you can select all
the columns that end with the suffix or
you can match against our gaps and
that's very useful when you have well
organized data frames with consistent
column names with suffixes and prefixes
it makes it really easy to select grams
sometimes the action verbs and selection
verbs appear to work the same way
so here we have select height and we
have
transmuter height and we get exactly the
same result but it's useful to know
whether you have an action verb or a
selection verb regardless because if you
change the input a bit here no one
supplying one and for a selection verb
it means since it understands current
positions it means select the first
column whereas for an action verbs it
will create a new vector from you input
and in this case recycle it to the
dataframe size and we get a column of
ones so what about goodbye that that's
an interesting case because most users
think it's like selection verb but
actually it's an action verb and if you
try to pass a selection helper to group
by you will get this error that the
variables can that are not found and
we've made it an action verb because
it's actually very helpful to create
this new discrete these new vectors on
the fly where you discriminate between
groups and so in this example here I'm
grouping by the observations whose
height above threshold and then I'm
summarizing on the fly and I get the
next table of Daenerys so what can you
do if you have an action verb like group
by and you want to really pass a
selection or you can use the at variance
the scoped word and with this so we have
like muted at summarize attend group by
add and a bunch of others and they take
a selection inside this little function
of us which is which is a function that
does the coating that gets the blueprint
and then passes it to group by add and
within this you can pass a selection and
here in this example we are grouping by
all the columns that ends whisker O so
that's
see how we can create those evil
functions and there are three challenges
here first there is the need to to quote
the inputs to get selections and actions
from the users then there is the need to
modify these selections or actions and
then pass them around to other toy
dealer functions so the second one is
small complex at the other that's where
you need to understand all the tidy but
theory you need to use the tied evil to
like bang bang and we are not going to
talk about this today we are going to
focus on the first and third challenges
and to do that we going to pass the dirt
so here we have the simplest function
you can create by passing the dots we
typically take a data frame and then we
take dots and we pass it pass it through
to another tied eval functions and that
means that all the arguments that use a
surprise through the dots now it's the
responsibility of our functions in the
play or tidier or the Divis promise to
do the quoting and to create actions or
selections so you don't have to do
anything and you sort of both challenges
one and three in the same go so it's a
bit limited but it can be very useful
and we are going to see three examples
of it so first we are going to create
selection verb with the player then we
are going to see how we can transform
that selection verb to an action verb
instead and then we are going to use the
idea to complexify the pipeline so as i
mentioned most d player verbs have
variant suffix with at and they take
selections does it so they can be very
useful if you want to create a selection
that we study by passing the dots and
two of these are a bit different to the
others because they they take a
selection but they also take a function
and then they apply the function to each
column
that's part of the selection so it's a
bit like L apply or the function map in
power and it works like this you pass
the dataframe you pass the section side
part and then a function that can also
be a lambda so with the formula notation
and it applies the body of the function
on each column from the section and
that's as if you had created this much
longer
a samurai's code so it can take a
function a single function but it can
also take a list of functions so here
I'm creating a list is a function that
takes the average and then the standard
deviation and when you pass a list of
functions it applies each of those to
each column in turn and spreads the
results across the columns so our first
tied eval function will be called
summarized cells for selections and we
are wrapping around summarize at we pass
the dots to vas we pass the list of
summary functions to it and then you can
use it by passing selections and you get
the table of summaries and the nice
thing about it is that it works with
groups so it's always a good idea to
think about what happens when you pass a
group table to your tidier function if
you are using de playa verbs and in this
case it will create the summaries for
each each group so what if we wanted to
supply actions instead of selections and
when you want to create an action verb
one very useful function to pass the
dots with two is twins mute because
that's like the fundamental action verb
in the player because it takes actions
creates vectors from these actions and
it returns you the table that contains
these vectors so on top you have the
previous implementation of summary
service and now we have
the new function summarized acts and we
just pass adults to transmute and then
instead of using summarize at we use
summarize all which will apply the
summary functions on all the columns of
the table that it is passed and that
gets you an action function that uses
the idea and you can create new vectors
in the input so it works like in mutate
or table and here I'm trying to compute
a BMI but I don't have height probably
scales and so I can pass a first action
that creates height in meters and then I
can compute the BMI with raise this and
it creates the summaries for both
vectors and it works again with with
groups so the this tip with the result
spread across : it's it's not so tightly
so what if we wanted to gather it
together them across the rows so that's
obviously a job for tidy R and we are
going to add a getter step to our
pipeline and we'll see that handling the
groups will be a bit trickier in this
case so that's how it looks we still
positive to transmute but now we gather
all the columns created with transmute
with the function gather we group by the
variable and we summarize we applied the
summary functions on the column value
and that gets you the much nicer table
the problem is that here it doesn't work
with group tipper so that's why it's
always a good idea when you create a new
function to see what happens when you
pass a group data frame and the reason
is that gather
also gather the grouping variables and
you cannot apply the summaries and this
grouping variables without getting these
errors so the way to fixing is really
simple we gather everything except the
grouping variables and now it works and
we get this nice table of summaries so
to sum up passing the dots is like maybe
the simplest way to create a tidy Val
function it's a good when you when you
create one it's a good it's good to
think about whether you need a an action
verb or selection verb and then you can
use the at variance if you need
selections or you can use transmute if
you need actions or on your dot ID VAR
functions if you pass the dots to it and
that's a function it takes selection
then it means that your wrapper will
take selections as well so it requires
no letter of Tydeus verbs so you can
create the appropriate pipeline but
that's no letters you are already
familiar with and if you learn new
things then it's transferable to your
day-to-day workflow and then finally
it's always a good idea to think about
group tables because it gets you like
useful results when when you need to
compute things by groups so my slides
are on speaker deck and thank you
we have time for several questions so
raise your hand and we'll throw
something at you
I think there's one in the back maybe
color I have a question about the slide
where you summarize by rows this one
yeah yep so we're in that function is it
doing it by rows oh it's because you get
the older new vectors that you create
with the the inputs from the user and
then we group by the variables right and
then the summaries from summarize adds
will apply for each group of the
variables that were created in the dots
so that's the trick
you
[Music]